working in comedy I spend all my off
time watching a lot of documentaries so
this was so exciting it's like a little
kid getting to like jump into a video
game
you're the sunniest state ignoring the
Sun exactly the Sunshine State and
you're not allowed to provide energy
through sunshine I've sort of been
learning along doing this documentary
and I've started like reading articles
on my own and I'm texting my family and
friends and now they're learning along
with me we have some very powerful power
companies that have monopoly over the
marketplace and they want to keep it
that way and solar would be a threat
that's really what it comes down to we
have a ton of potential here but hardly
any solar it's less than 1% currently in
the state of Florida 82% of voting
Floridians are in favor of measures that
would make it easier for people to go
solar here the main thing that the story
wants to get across that I think most
people don't know is that solar really
is ready for deployment and the
roadblocks that exists are mainly
political so which one would you sign if
you want us to see more solar in Florida
I think I've seen this one before you
have seen that you guys live scene a
green one do you know who's behind this
I've booked the energy company you guys
started a pro solar petition and the
energy companies created an anti solar
petition that looks like a pro solar
petition exactly so many people want it
and it's being blocked by so few it's
infuriating this is a solution to the
climate crisis that we're in right now
this is an easy solution I hope people
feel that way too and make solar happen
faster